you were a hippie they gave me a show
yeah yeah um you know peepees story well
I grew up in Santa Cruz California where
being a hippie is just sort of a default
position and so I certainly went through
my I got really into The Grateful Dead
sure this is like when I was like 15 it
is hippy though everybody's you're born
a hippie you're naked you're like
tripping I have a giant beard yeah
you're like you've only been eating you
know your mother's milk that's right I
was gonna say vegan but she's not vegan
do all do all hippies child or adult
subsist only on their mother's breast
milk for as long as you can because I
only breastfed till I was like 16 what
about you it's my job to make you look
good yes that's normal
yeah that's that's not strange the whole
thing is strange yeah you went to second
base with your mom and you loved it and
can I keep this Adam Scott everybody
the season finale of Parks and Rec airs
Thursday April 24th at 8:30 on NBC and
The Secret Life of Walter Mitty is
available now on DVD with Adam as well
Adam Scott one more time